Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Schon gehört, Facebook heißt jetzt Meta.
Na dann benennst du halt die Meta-Ebene um in Face.
Logbuch Netzpolitik, Nummer 411 vom 29. Oktober 2021 und da sind wir wieder und es sind aufregende Zeiten und spezielle Zahlen stehen im Raum, überall und es sind Einsen und Nullen. Schon wieder Linus, Einsen und Nullen. Oder ein A. Das stimmt auch. Je nachdem. Choose your Zahlensystem. Auf jeden Fall gestern, der 28. Oktober, das ist nämlich quasi unser Geburtstag gewesen und jetzt gibt es Logbuch Netzpolitik seit zehn Jahren.
Zehn Jahre.
Zehn Jahre. Das ist in der Tat eine ganze Menge Holz. Und wäre natürlich ein toller Anlass gewesen, irgendwie zu feiern, einen großen Event zu machen. Hütte voll. Ihr wisst schon, all dieses ganze Brimborium, was wir eigentlich auch mal zu vollen Sendungszahlen gerne gemacht haben, sich jetzt auch irgendwie angeboten hätte. Aber naja gut, wisst ihr ja, alle ist derzeit so richtig keine Option. Da haben wir uns gedacht, na dann, machen wir halt was anderes, was ganz Einfaches. Und haben uns gedacht, naja dann schenken wir euch ein paar Shirts. Ihr müsst sie natürlich bezahlen.
Wir schenken euch ein paar Shirts.
Wir schenken euch die Möglichkeit, sie zu erwerben. Genau, also wir setzen jetzt die Tage. Ein Shop auf, hat jetzt leider zum heutigen Tag noch nicht ganz fertig, aber da ganz zuversichtlich, dass wir das zusammengeklöppelt bekommen. Ja, und dann machen wir das so auf Vorbestellung erst mal. Das heißt, bis zu einem bestimmten Tag müssen dann die Bestellungen eingegangen sein. Und dann soll das so gemacht werden, dass ihr dann das noch in diesem Jahr, sprich vor Weihnachten, bekommt.
Ja, es ist schwierig, das zu versprechen. Weil zu Weihnachten einfach der DHL-Aufwand so hoch ist, dass die mitunter sehr lange Lieferzeiten dann haben. Also wir hatten das zum Beispiel bei der RC3 letztes Jahr. Da wurde eigentlich alles am 6.12. sind die letzten Pakete rausgegangen. Und die standen dann aber, weißt du, also Paket raus heißt in dieser Menge dann eben, ein DHL-Auto kommt, macht einen Container voll und dann steht der bei DHL auf einmal auf dem Hof. Und dann standen halt mitunter versandte Pakete, wo die Leute auch schon eine Versandbenachrichtigung hatten, noch mal eine Woche bei DHL. Dann sind die Leute irgendwann nervös geworden und haben dann halt ihre Pakete wie sowas am 8. bekommen, haben natürlich zwischendurch gedacht, meine Sendung wurde gar nicht versendet oder war es nicht alles. Also da ist die Logistik ist ja ohnehin am Limit, einfach dadurch, dass die sich natürlich auch die Kosten enorm versuchen zu optimieren. Und zu Weihnachten wird sie dann gerne auch mal über ihre Grenzen gebracht. Wir werden hier glaube ich in der Sendung dann noch mal genau sagen, wann wir diesen Shop dann auch wieder schließen oder die Vorbestellungsphase beenden. Oder sagen wir mal, die sagen, ab jetzt braucht er nicht mehr damit zu rechnen, dass es zu Weihnachten kommt. Die Idee ist eigentlich, dass wir halt über einen Zeitraum von wahrscheinlich so drei, vier Wochen den Shop laufen lassen, dann wird der irgendwann zu Ende sein. Dann werden die Sachen produziert und dann werden sie im Zweifelsfall so in der ersten Dezemberwoche versendet und dann ist es schon sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass man das nicht bis Weihnachten hat, sagen wir mal so. Das ist ungefähr der Zeitplan, dadurch, dass wir diese Produktion dann auch wieder erst machen. Nachdem bestellt wurde, können wir zum Beispiel auch Hoodies anbieten, was ja im Winter auch ganz nett ist. Und ja, da werden wir, glaube ich, eine ganz nette Runde an Kleidungsstücken für euch bereithalten, die ihr bestellen könnt, wenn ihr uns unterstützen möchtet, durch Werbung. Ja, also für Werbung muss man bezahlen, das kennt ihr ja. Und deswegen müsst ihr eben Werbung für uns auch bezahlen, wenn ihr sie auf eurer Kleidung haben wollt.
Ja, ihr zahlt es selber, ihr seid nicht das Produkt, das ist das Gute da dran, ja?
Das Produkt hängt einfach auf der Brust, wie sich das gehört.
Und ich bin jetzt einfach mal so, schaut mal am Abend des 3. November auf www.logbuchnetzpolitik.de, da werdet ihr mit Sicherheit einen Link finden, der euch sagt, wie ihr zu diesem Shop gelangt und wie ihr euch da eine Freude machen könnt.
Genau.
So, das bringt uns zu unseren Standards und die Fehlermeldung, die jetzt kommt, ist eigentlich völlig unangemessen, weil wir haben die Länge ja gerade genannt. HTTP Status Code 411 ist nämlich Length Required und das ist etwas, was der Server dem Browser zurückmodst, wenn der eine Anfrage gestellt hat und der Server hätte es aber ganz gerne mal ganz genau, nämlich mit einer Längenangabe, wie viele Daten denn jetzt übertragen werden sollen und das interessiert eigentlich auch keinem Menschen, aber ich kann nur sagen, wir haben ja die Länge jetzt gerade genannt, das waren zehn Jahre. Also von daher, bitte keine weiteren Fehlermeldungen.
Ja, Facebook hat sich umbenannt. Wer hat uns verraten?
Das ist wirklich sehr schön. Jetzt passt dir der Spruch mal total.
Ich verfolge das ja jetzt nicht unbedingt, dieses Facebook, aber das scheint mir schon sehr komisch gewesen zu sein, was der gute Mark Zuckerberg vorgestellt hat.
Ach so, ja. Also er hat ja so eine Keynote gehalten und da irgendwie eine Stunde lang rumgeschwurbelt. Ich hab mir das nicht komplett angeschaut, nur so in Auszügen. Im Kern ist es halt so sein Traum, das Metaverse aus No-Crash und fabuliert sich da halt so eine Cyber-3D-Schein-VR-Welt zusammen, in der dann alle sozialen Interaktionen stattfinden sollen und keine Ahnung, ob er sich wirklich so vorstellt, dass man dann wieder bei Matrix dann alle so zuhause fett mit Pommes irgendwie noch auf der Hose und Ketchupflecken einfach mit so einer VR-Brille auf nur noch so gelähmt im Sessel sitzen und dann irgendwie dort komplett mental abwesend nur noch in dieser 3D-Welt rumfliegen. Das sind so Fantasien von so Leuten, wo ich auch immer das Gefühl habe, dass sie einfach auch den Bezug zum echten Leben schon komplett verloren haben. Ich will jetzt hier nicht unbedingt zum finalen Digital-Zweifler werden, aber es gibt schon wirklich andere Sorgen und am Ende wissen wir halt, was Facebook will. Facebook will eure permanente Anwesenheit in ihrem Kaufkanal, um an allem in irgendeiner Form beteiligt zu sein. Das ist das Ziel. Und dieses ganze Wischiwaschi von irgendwie, was sie denn doch da alles Tolles Soziales erreichen können und wie schön das doch für die Menschheit ist, up your ass, Marc, up your ass.
Ich glaube, der hat also entweder hat der Black Mirror geguckt oder der hat Black Mirror nicht geguckt. Und beides wäre irgendwie komisch. Also was, ich frage, also was, dann guckt man irgendwie Konzerte, zwei Leute sind da, der dritte sitzt halt irgendwie als blaues Hologramm irgendwie da. Und dann kaufst du dir irgendwelche NFTs, damit dein Avatar irgendwie eine andere Hose anhat oder so.
Ich meine, was er da im Prinzip heraufbeschwört ist, so ein dauerpandemischer Zustand.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, dass der in Anbetracht dieser Facebook-Falls sieht, was ihm blüht und jetzt mal langsam einen auf Meise machen möchte, weißt du, damit sie ihn da im Zweifelsfall nicht verknacken für das Ungemach, was die in die Welt gebracht haben, weißt du, dass der im Zweifelsfall dann sagen kann, nee, Metaversum hier, Leute. Alle sagen, komm, der ist einfach nur verrückt, so lass den armen Mann so, gib dem seine Rokulesbrille.
Ich hätte ja kein Problem, wenn er sich in sein eigenes Metaversum abseilt und dann bleibt er da auch alleine und ist irgendwie glücklich mit seiner Cyberwelt. Aber ich glaube halt auch an diese Vision nicht. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt gesehen, wie weit wir kommen mit diesem Online-Only und so weiter.
Also einen sehr schönen Kommentar hat Jason Köbler auf weis.com geschrieben, der sagt, ungefähr zur Hälfte des delusionalen Fiebertraums, der da mit Facebooks größte Produktankündigung aller Zeiten war, sagt Mark Zuckerberg, dass die letzten Jahre sehr, wie übersetzt man den, humbling, nicht demütigend, sondern, wie heißt das? Demütigend ist ja quasi aktiv und humbling ist ja so passiv, ich hätte mir das vorher überlegen müssen.
Demut erzeugend.
Was ist das für ein Versetz? Ja, so sehr ernüchternd. Ja, genau. Ernüchternd oder bescheiden machen lassen, was es für uns war und es hat schon sehr, komm, ich weiß, was du sagst, ja, es war sehr ernüchternd und wir haben viel gelernt und mit aller Demut kündigen wir jetzt an Meta. Wir übernehmen jetzt alles. Wir sitzen jetzt hier, du kannst jetzt in der NFT und deine Freunde leuchten nur noch blau in irgendeiner Brille. Das scheint nicht unbedingt so, dass sie da jetzt sehr viel Demut mitgenommen haben aus der letzten Zeit.
Ach, auf gar keinen Fall. Also ich meine, das muss man bei ihm auch nicht erwarten. Aber um es vielleicht gleich nochmal richtig einzusortieren, wie das jetzt mit diesen Namen ist, also die Produktnamen bleiben, so wie sie sind, zumindest vorerst. Sprich, Facebook gibt es auch weiterhin noch. Bloß Facebook bezeichnet jetzt ausschließlich eben das Netzwerk.
Genau, aber ihr müsst jetzt dann eben auf metaebene.me gehen.
Out, out, you demons of stupidity. Auf keinen Fall, aber ich meine, sie haben sich dann halt sozusagen jetzt für ihre Dachorganisation, so ähnlich wie Google das gemacht hat, also die Dachorganisation von Google heißt halt Alphabet, was auch schon so ein Name ist, der irgendwie bis heute noch nicht von der Zunge geht. Vielleicht auch nicht soll, ja, also vielleicht geht es ihnen einfach auch darum, quasi ihr Unternehmen auch so ein bisschen rauszunehmen. Und jetzt können sie halt Ankündigungen machen mit Meta, hat gesagt. Und Meta macht dies und Meta macht das und es wird nicht so automatisch mit Facebook verbunden. Mit deinem Produkt und so. Macht natürlich auch in gewisser Hinsicht Sinn, quasi so eine Überinstanz noch mal anders zu benennen, insbesondere wenn da ein ganzer Produktwald nicht gerade besonders einheitlich benannt ist, weil es halt im Wesentlichen zugekaufte Produkte von anderen Helden waren. Also Instagram, Whatsapp und so. Das passt ja alles nicht in dasselbe Namenschema. Insofern ist Meta halt schon ein ganz cooler Name. Wusste ich ja schon vor 15 Jahren. Ja es interessiert einen eigentlich auch nicht groß. Sind jetzt schon alle Witze gemacht. Aber ich kann mich ja wirklich Face nennen jetzt einfach.
ID Wallet. Das Thema ID Wallet war ja eigentlich hier auch schon längst abschließend erörtert. Und zwar diese ja doch wirklich in richtig breitflächig gefailte ID App, die da vor ein paar Wochen online ging, für ein paar Stunden, um dann quasi dauerhaft wieder offline zu gehen. Eine absolute Blamage für diejenigen, die das Ding an den Start gebracht haben. Also auch wirklich, wenn du dir das anschaust, du gehst als Bundesregierung hin und lässt irgendwelche windigen Blockchain-Spinner auf irgendwie Probe-Hardware mal eben ausgerechnet, die eine der wichtigsten hoheitlichen Aufgaben machen. Ich warte noch darauf, dass sie demnächst nochmal versuchen, eine Notenbank per App zu launchen oder sowas. Also totaler Quatsch. Und jetzt war es ja so, dass sehr kurz nach der Veröffentlichung dann eben auch demonstriert wurde, dass es hier einen relativ fundamentalen Fehler gab bei dieser QR-Code-Authentifizierung. Der Weg ist ja so, wenn du dich dann authentifizierst, scanst du einen QR-Code und in dem QR-Code steht drin, gegenüber wem du dich jetzt wie ausweist. Und für die App steht da drin, wohin du diese Daten dann senden musst, wohin diese App dann die Daten senden soll. Und du kannst quasi trivial einen QR-Code bauen, der sagt, ich bin, was weiß ich, die Polizei Bremen. Und die Daten, die du dann jetzt hier abgibst, die schickst du bitte an, was weiß ich, datenloch.linusneumann.de, schöne, geile Datensammlung. Und diese App würde das nicht erkennen. Das war also quasi ein fundamentaler Fehler dieses Authentifizierungsprotokolls. Es gibt auch andere Wege, die sind dann aber nicht mehr reindezentral und dann hast du quasi da wieder den ganzen Sinn verloren. Also du weißt dich zwar aus, aber die Stelle gegenüber, der du dich ausweist, braucht sich nicht auszuweisen. Und das Angriffsszenario, was daraus eben erfolgen würde, wäre zum Beispiel Überkleben von QR-Codes oder ähnliche Scherze. So, das Ding herauszufinden, hat ja irgendwie, weiß nicht, 24 Stunden nach Launch der App gedauert, so ungefähr. Und stellte sich dann natürlich schon die Frage, sag mal, das ist eigentlich unwahrscheinlich, dass sie davon keine Kenntnis hatten. Es gab ja dann auch auf GitHub die entsprechenden Diskussionen, da musste man natürlich hin, da würde man jetzt mal vermuten, dass was weiß ich, eine Dorobär nicht unbedingt auf GitHub die Diskussionen der Entwicklerinnen verfolgt. Also gab es einmal eine kleine Anfrage von Anke Domscheit-Berg, in der die Frage gestellt wurde, sag mal, gab es vielleicht Pentests von diesem Ding? Und wurde bei diesen Pentests vielleicht darauf hingewiesen, dass es diese Schwachstelle gibt?
Also Pentests, Penetration-Tests und Sicherheits-Tests?
Genau, also Sicherheitsüberprüfungen, die man üblicherweise vor der Veröffentlichung einer solchen App macht. Also gab es eigentlich einen Pentest? Wenn ja, hat er auf diese Schwachstelle hingewiesen. Und wenn ja, mit welcher Begründung habt ihr das ignoriert? Und die Antwort ließ schon sehr tief blicken. Die war nämlich so, ja, das Szenario ist nicht relevant. Mit anderen Worten, sie haben natürlich dadurch, dass sie die Begründung verlesen haben, sie haben nicht gesagt, es gab Pentest, sie haben nicht gesagt, wir hatten Kenntnis von dieser Schwachstelle, aber sie haben die Begründung geliefert, warum sie die Schwachstelle ignoriert haben. Und dann gab es außerdem, das war parallel, eine Anfrage an Frag den Staat, wo gesagt wurde, gib doch mal bitte die Sicherheitsüberprüfungen. Und das ist sehr unterhaltsam. Da findest du, die wurde dann beantwortet, also eine Anfrage an das BMI. Und die wurde dann eben von dem BMI beantwortet, mit den Dokumenten. Da findest du dann im Prinzip so eine Zusammenfassung des Penetration Tests und da steht drin identifizierte Schwachstellen. Erste Schwachstelle mit mittlerem Risiko. Keine Verifikation der Hotel-Endpunkte. Also Hotel war der Probefall. Ein Eingreifer kann durch einen eigenen Endpunkt Daten eines sich registrierenden Benutzers erlangen. Die Überprüfung ist derzeit durch eine einfache Anzeige der URL dem Benutzer überlassen. Da ein Benutzer hier aber keinen Vergleich zu einer korrekten URL hat, kann diese nur schwer von einem Benutzer überprüft werden. Das ist die spezifische Schwachstelle.
Gleich als erstes.
Gleich als allererstes. Die sind sortiert nach Mittel und Niedrig. Diese ist als Mittel benannt. Das heißt also übersetzt, die hatten von dieser Schwachstelle Kenntnis. Die haben die App mit dieser Schwachstelle also wissentlich diese App gelauncht. Und wussten von dieser Schwachstelle.
Weil sie das wahrscheinlich dann nicht als plausibles Szenario angesehen haben. Nach dem Motto, wer würde denn sowas machen?
Ich hatte das ja glaube ich schon in der Sendung gesagt. Die Schwachstelle, ich bleibe übrigens auch dabei, die ist von geringer praktischer Relevanz. Das ist nicht so, dass damit massenhafter Identitätsdiebstahl passieren wird. Es ist aber trotzdem eine, die funktioniert und die auch angewendet werden wird. Sei es nur, um sich ein bisschen auf die Brust zu schlagen. Du kannst ja nicht sagen, Leute, jetzt hier mit 5 Blockchains der neue Personalausweis voll geil als App oder ein neuer Führerschein als App und dann eine bekannte Schwachstelle drin haben. Man kann natürlich potenziell eine Schwachstelle irgendwann als mittleres Risiko einstufen und dann sich entscheiden, sie zu lassen. Aber doch nicht in einem frischen Produkt. Du kannst ja nicht mit bekannten Schwachstellen an die Öffentlichkeit gehen. Zumal diese Standard ja durchaus die Möglichkeit ihnen überlässt, das werden sie im Zweifelsfall auch tun, diesen Kommunikationsteil oder diese Authentifizierungsprotokoll mit dieser Schwachstelle, das halt zu deaktivieren. Das hätten sie ja auch vorher schon machen können. Aber also mit bekannter Schwachstelle.
Ja, nicht nur mit bekannter Schwachstelle. Vielleicht ist deine Einschätzung so, dass mir jetzt nicht aus dem Stand viele Szenarios einfallen, wie man das jetzt wirklich so ausnutzen kann, dass irgendwas konkret Böses, Negatives passiert.
Doch, doch, also auf jeden Fall das auf jeden Fall. Die Frage eskaliert das. Also klar, die Angriff, die Schwachstelle ist ja klar. Du musst nur eben ein QR-Code überkleben. Und dadurch skaliert das nicht so enorm.
Ja gut, aber naja, es skaliert schon in eine Richtung, nämlich jeder dieser Fälle hat irgendwie mediale Power, insbesondere auf sozialen Netzwerken.
Und ein Schaden für die Person. Genau wie das eine, Identitätsdiebstahl ist ja schon schlimm genug.
Genau, dann geht das gleich irgendwie auf Twitter rum. Wir wissen, wie schnell das geht. Und auch zu Recht an der Stelle. Und wie ist es dann so mit der Akzeptanz dieser Technologie? Ich meine, wir sehen ja schon, was für Probleme wir haben, irgendwie so Impfstoffe durchzukriegen, wo einfach nur Unsinn erzählt wird, der nicht belegt werden kann. Was ist mit einer Technologie, wo es um die persönliche Sicherheit geht, wo belegt werden kann, dass es nicht funktioniert. Und was mich besonders fertig macht daran, es ist ja nicht so, dass wir jetzt dieses spezifische Problem nicht auch schon einige Male gesehen haben. Und wir kennen eigentlich genau das gleiche Problem auch aus anderen Fällen. Erstmal unser Mobiltelefon muss sich zwar gegenüber dem Netz authentifizieren, aber das Netz muss sich nicht uns gegenüber authentifizieren. Was ist die Folge?
Imseacatcher.
Imseacatcher, irgendwie, man weiß nicht, in welchem Netz man wirklich unterwegs ist. Irgendeine Infrastruktur gibt vor, es wäre mein Mobilfunknetz... Scheiße. WLAN, nächste Haltestelle. Genau derselbe Scheißdreck. Die einzige Identifikation ist dieser bekloppte Name, den jeder irgendwie einfach irgendwo reinschreiben kann. Wenn du halt aussehen willst wie ein Telekom-Hotspot, dann machst du halt einen auf und der heißt dann Telekom. So, und diese ganze Komplexität, das mal zu überprüfen, darüber ist einfach nie nachgedacht worden. Es ist immer dieses einseitige, du musst dich jetzt hier mal komplett ausweisen, aber der Polizist, der mich nach dem Ausweis fragt, der darf da irgendwie auch mit einem Schnorchel auf dem Kopf und mit einer Badehose und einer Zigarette in der Hand vor mir rumstehen und sagen, er ist Polizist. Würdest du sowas als Polizist so akzeptieren?
Also bei WLAN und Mobilfunk gab es dann seit 2G noch mal ein paar Weiterentwicklungen, über die ich jetzt gar nicht diskutieren will, weil ich will noch auf den zweiten Punkt Ihnen aufdenken.
Aber es ist von Anfang an immer vergessen worden. Das ist das, was ich sagen möchte.
Jaja, naja, und das, was ich sagen möchte, ist, es ist nicht vergessen worden, sondern es wurde Ihnen hier konkret gesagt mit einem klaren Risiko und die haben sich entschieden, das zu ignorieren. Aber außerdem gab es eine Überprüfung des BSI. Das BSI hat sich diese ID-Wallet-Lösung angeschaut. Und ich bin jetzt nicht dafür bekannt, ein besonderer Fan des BSI zu sein. Aber wenn die mal was Technisches richtig sagen, freue ich mich ja auch sehr. Also wie gesagt, ich bin insgesamt oder sagen wir mal so, ich bin der politisch auktorinierten Rolle des BSI kritisch gegenüber, aber selbstverständlich sage ich mal den Leuten im BSI wohlgesonnen. Und ja, was jetzt hier schreiben, das ist jetzt die BSI-Bewertung von dieser ID-Wallet-Geschichte. Durch die Nutzung der Blockchain-basierten Lösung im SSI-Piloten wird die Komplexität und damit einhergehend die grundsätzliche Anfälligkeit für Sicherheitslücken des gesamten Systems bei unklarem Nutzen deutlich erhöht. Das ist alles, was du dazu sagen musst. Das ist ein wunderschöner Satz. Durch die Verwendung der Blockchain kein erkennbarer Nutzen, aber erhöhte Komplexität und damit grundsätzliche Anfälligkeit. Und das ist ein sehr schöner Satz. Und der ist sehr wahr.
Kannst du in dem Zusammenhang auch nochmal den Begriff SSI kurz erläutern, weil der wird in der ganzen Debatte nirgends vor erklärt.
Self-Sovereign Identities. Das ist an dieser Stelle tatsächlich unerheblich. Das haben wir in der letzten Sendung ja auch schon mehrmals erklärt. Was sich dahinter verbirgt, sind diese Self-Sovereign Identities. Und sie nennen das hier SSI Pilot, weil das das ist, was sie geprüft haben. Letztendlich eine Implementierung dessen, was nachher auch ID Wallet war. Also der entscheidende Satz, durch die Nutzung der Blockchain wird die Komplexität und die grundsätzliche Anfälligkeit für Sicherheitslücken des gesamten Systems deutlich erhöht, bei unklarem Nutzen. Und jetzt weiter geht's. Viele Ziele können auch auf Basis klassischer PKI-basierter Technologien ebenso umgesetzt werden, die bei Ausweitung des Betriebs auf eine größere Menge an Parteien in jedem Fall zur Sicherstellung der Authentizität von Nachrichten dieser Parteien erforderlich sind. Sie sagen also, du kommst gar nicht an PKI vorbei. Die brauchst du nämlich, um die Authentizität beider Parteien darstellen zu können. Da gehen sie im Prinzip nämlich auf diese Schwachstelle ein, dass jeder sagen kann, ich mache hier irgendwas. Sie sagen im Prinzip, du brauchst am Ende klassische PKI, um nämlich die andere Partei auch authentifizieren zu können. Für den Betrieb des Blockchain-Netzwerks und den Identitätsnachweis werden kryptografische Protokolle und Verfahren eingesetzt, welche vom BSI nicht empfohlen werden und welche teilweise nicht standardisiert sind und noch experimentellen Charakter haben. Für diese liegen bisher keine ausreichenden Sicherheitsaussagen oder Sicherheitsnachfase vor, welche eine positive Bewertung ermöglichen. Das ist so der Punkt, an dem du sagen müsstest, okay, dann kann man halt nochmal den Arne Schönbohm anrufen und sagen, können Sie mir bitte nochmal erklären, was da steht? Verstehe ich das richtig, dass das da steht? Wir sollten da unbedingt die Finger vorn lassen. Ja, haben sie sich entschieden zu ignorieren. Und das ist halt schon, also das ist wirklich, was sind das für Leute? Also wenn du so etwas ignorierst, so eine Einschätzung des BSI, so eine Einschätzung deiner unabhängigen Penetration Tester, dann weißt du, du bist halt wirklich irgendwie in die Blockchain-Cool-Aid gefallen.
Aber Linus, gucke mal, du weißt doch, wie das ist. Das musst du doch jetzt einfach noch zum Ende der Legislaturperiode und vor der Wahl einfach noch raus. Das würde doch so schnell keiner merken.
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann es mir nicht erklären, wie man, also das ist so, ich sehe da nichts. Also ich sehe, die müssen doch, also kann jetzt auch nicht sein, also diese Leute, die irgendwie Fans dieser Technologien sind, da gibt es ja so eine kleine Sekte, die das ja immer noch unglaublich geil findet und alle als doof bezeichnet, die sagen, warum wollt ihr dafür eine Blockchain nehmen? Nein, warum eine Blockchain? Also diese wirklich keiner Rationalargumentation zugänglich sind. Was?
Ich bitte dich, wenn El Salvador das macht.
Also wirklich, es ist, und man muss auch, ich habe das ja hier auch schon öfter gesagt, weißt du, ich kann ja verstehen, dass der Staat sagt, oh Blockchain, da müssen wir jetzt mitmachen. Aber gerade diese verteilten Ledger, also das, was man gemein den Blockchain bezeichnet, die wurden ja nun mal überhaupt erfunden, um Staaten unnötig zu machen, um staatliche Hoheit letztendlich zu untergraben. Also Bitcoin ist nichts anderes als zu sagen, wir wollen keine Notenbank und wir wollen kein Bankensystem, das potenziell unsere Zahlungen zensieren kann. Nicht, dass das irgendwie ein Problem der Allgemeinheit wäre. Und entsprechend wurde Bitcoin ja auch eigentlich nur bei denen beliebt, die halt, sagen wir mal, Zensur ihrer oder Einfrieren ihrer finanziellen Transaktionen fürchten müssen, nämlich Steuerhinterzieher und Drogenhändler. Man darf nicht vergessen. Was diese Technologien als Design hatten, unnötig zu machen. Deswegen ist das so skurril, dass dann ausgerechnet ein Staat sagt, egal, lecker, funny, will man jetzt Blockchain. Die haben wirklich nicht verstanden, was sie da machen. Aber okay, lassen wir das. Das sind wirklich Money Quotes, dass das BSI hier sagt, Anfälligkeit für Schwachstellen bei unklarem Nutzen deutlich erhöht. Das wäre eine Sache zu sagen, die wussten das nicht. Das ist auch nicht so zu entschuldigen. Aber jetzt müssen sie sich mal die Frage gefallen lassen, dass sie das wussten, dass sie absichtlich, wissentlich die App mit dieser Schwachstelle auf die Menschheit losgelassen haben. Dieses Ding ging ja dann auch tatsächlich mehr auf Doru Bär zurück als auf Andy Scheuer. Ich meine, das die beiden in einen Sack. Aber so sieht es damit aus. Dann haben wir mal wieder krassere Geschichten. Über die Staatstrojaner-Bude NSO, die ja den Staatstrojaner Pegasus betreibt. Und da haben unsere Freunde vom Citizen Lab einen neuen Report unter dem Titel Breaking the News. Das ist ein sehr schönes Wortspiel. Und zwar wurde der Journalist Ben Hubbard mit Pegasus gehackt. Und der hat auch über dieses Thema durchaus berichtet. Er hat irgendwie über Saudi-Arabien kritisch geschrieben und ein Buch geschrieben über den Mohammed bin Zayman, diesen saudischen Kronprinzen dort. Der wurde im Juli 2020 und Juli 2021 mit Pegasus infiziert.
Also nicht er, sondern seine Telefone.
Ja, genau. Aber er hatte sich vorher schon bei der NSO-Group beschwert, dass er getargetet wurde. Er hat im Prinzip quasi gesagt, ey, hier, es gibt Pegasus-Hacking-Versuche auf mein Telefon, liebe NSO. Ihr sagt ja, ihr schützt die Menschenrechte und so. Ich wollte kurz darauf hinweisen, ich bin kein Terrorist und die Saudis hacken mich. Und tja, da war dann halt irgendwie, war das dann aber unerheblich. Hat NSO jetzt nicht weiter interessiert. Ich meine, das ist ja kein Kunde. Sondern er ist in dem Fall tatsächlich das Produkt. Seine Informationen sind das Produkt. Entsprechend konnte er sich auch nicht beschweren. Das ist natürlich schon wirklich, also ich meine, hat er einen sehr, natürlich, entsprechenden Artikel darüber geschrieben, was das auch mit ihm als Journalisten macht. Und ich sag mal, die New York Times ist jetzt auch durchaus, würde ich sagen, eines der renommiertesten. Eine der renommiertesten journalistischen Institutionen der Welt. Und ja, das ist halt schon einfach eine heftige Nummer. Und auch nur einer von eben sehr, sehr vielen Fällen. Wir erinnern uns ja an dieses League, wo es ja irgendwie um viele Tausende Staatsoberhörbter, Journalistinnen und so weitergehen. Also, diese Sachen muss man immer im Hinterkopf halten. Aber natürlich ist die Argumentation eines Staates dann eben, ja, dann müssen wir aber, dann müssen wir sowas selber machen. Oder dann kaufen wir halt die menschenrechtsfreundlichen Revisionen dieser App. Und wie gesagt, das ist ja das Unternehmen, mit dem BKA und BND ja bereits Verträge haben, wie wir in den letzten Sendungen auch berichtet haben. Also, das ist ein Unternehmen, das auch mit deutschem Geld derartige Aktionen durchführt. Ich denke häufig so, weißt du, wenn wir die Staatstrojaner-Debatte, ich kann jetzt alle, alle Debatten sind ja zehn Jahre alt, mindestens. Weil wir sie seit zehn Jahren auch in Logbuch Netzpolitik behandeln. Und davor, die Staatstrojaner-Debatte ist glaube ich sogar 15 bis 20 Jahre alt. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wann da diese erste Bundesverfassungsgerichtsverhandlung war, die in dem Grundrecht auf Integrität Informationsverarbeitender-Systeme mündete. Aber, also seit langer Zeit wird das diskutiert. Und das, was hier passiert mit NSOP Pegasus, ist im Prinzip das, wovor seit 10, 20 Jahren gewarnt wird. Und eigentlich noch krasser, als man es sich hätte vorstellen können. Also es ist wirklich so ein Fall von, wovor du dann irgendwie vor 10, 15, 20 Jahren gewarnt hast, wenn du da gesagt hättest, da wird es irgendwann einen international tätigen Konzern geben, der im Auftrag der Saudis New York Times-Journalisten hackt, dann hätten die gesagt, ja, stimmt, vielen Dank für Ihren Sachverstand. Vielleicht reden Sie mal hier mit professionellen Leuten nochmal über Ihren allgemeinen Lebensentwurf. Oder glaubst du, das ist so eine Geschichte, die überholt dich doch dann irgendwann die Realität?
Es ist ja laufend so, dass die Realität irgendwie immer schlimmer wird, als man das vorher so in Science-Fiction-Büchern gelesen hat. Ja, übrigens, Vorwärtsdatenspeicherung wurde erstmalig, laut Wikipedia, erstmals 1996 gefordert. Da war von Einführung von Mindestfristen für die Speicherung von Verbindungsdaten das erste Mal die Rede. Mit anderen Worten, das feiert jetzt auch schon 25 Jahre.
Ah, und zum Jubiläum hat sich dann die scheidende Bundesregierung noch schnell eingesetzt und hat gesagt, ja, hier Pläne der EU-Kommission zur Wiedereinführung und Ausweitung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und das stützen wir natürlich. Also die Kommission denkt sich jetzt, wir müssen jetzt zum Schutz der nationalen Sicherheit usw. Die machen quasi einen neuen Anlauf. Dabei hat ja, also ich meine, diese gesamten Vorratsdatengeschichten, die wurden ja immer wieder gefressen. Erst haben sie eine Richtlinie gemacht, dann hat Deutschland die umgesetzt, dann hieß es in Deutschland, ey, das geht nicht, was ihr da macht. Dann haben sie gesagt, ja, müssen wir aber wegen der Richtlinie machen. Dann müssen wir wegen der Richtlinie machen. Dann müssen wir wegen der Richtlinie machen. Dann müssen wir wegen der Richtlinie machen. Dann wurde die Richtlinie vom EGH nicht weggeballert. Dann haben sie gesagt, ja, hm, weil machen wir denn jetzt ja einen neuen Anlauf. Und die Leute sind ja schon auf dem Weg nach draußen. Da kacken sie dir noch ein ID Wallet auf den Tisch und noch mal ein Jahr zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und ja, was willst du dazu noch sagen?
Da haben wir eigentlich auch schon alles zu gesagt, weil so geht der Kreis halt immer wieder weiter. Und das ist jetzt einfach mal klar. Das ist auch eine Art heilige Kuh. Es ist nicht irgendwie, oh, hier gibt es ein Problem mit der Gesellschaft, das müssen wir jetzt mal lösen. Es ist mehr so eine Art Dogma einer konservativen Politik, dass so eine Polizeiarbeit sich quasi nur darüber realisieren ließe. Und das kommt sicherlich auch aus dem Apparat immer wieder heraus. Also selbst wenn Politiker dann immer wieder in den Polizeiapparat reinhorchen, dann kommt auch von dort wahrscheinlich nichts anderes. Wir brauchen mehr Daten, wir brauchen mehr Daten, wir brauchen mehr Daten. Naja, ich meine, das ist natürlich auch nicht einfach. Ich will jetzt niemanden in Schutz nehmen. Aber stell dir jetzt mal vor, morgen wärst du Bundeskanzler. Und du setzt dich mit der Polizei zusammen und sagst, naja, wie können wir denn hier mal euch helfen? Dann kommt die auch sofort damit an.
Nur noch mal kurz zur Geschichte. Es gibt hier im Spiegelartikel noch mal eine schöne Zusammenfassung. Die EU-Richtlinie für Vorratsdatenspeicherung kam 2006. Eine Richtlinie heißt, muss in nationale Gesetze umgesetzt werden. Das haben dann eben die europäischen Mitgliedsstaaten getan. Und da droht ja dann immer, wenn du das nicht machst, dann kriegste Ärger mit der EU. Dann hat der EuGH die Richtlinie 2014 wegen Verstoß gegen die europäische Grundrechtecharta für ungültig erklärt. Acht Jahre später. Aufgrund der Richtlinie waren aber natürlich jetzt Mitgliedsstaaten, die die nationalen Umsetzungsgesetze längst erfolgt. Mussten sie ja, um der Strafe zu entgehen. Dann wurde das deutsche Umsetzungsgesetz schon 2010 vom Bundesverfassungsgericht für verfassungswidrig erklärt. Also vier Jahre, bevor der EuGH das dann auch gemacht hat. Das war die Zeit, wo man dann in Deutschland sagte, oh mein Gott, das fürchterliche Bundesverfassungsgericht hat uns die Vorratsentschweichung weggenommen. Und jetzt kriegen wir eine Strafe von der EU. Wir müssen das jetzt machen. Dann haben sie nämlich 2015, obwohl das EuGH-Urteil jetzt inzwischen schon gesagt hat, die Richtlinie ist ungültig, haben sie 2015 noch mal ein Gesetz zur Vorratsentschweichung gemacht. Das wurde aber dann vom Oberverwaltungsgericht Münster, ich glaube in so einem Eilverfahren, zunächst ausgesetzt. Und dann ist es hoch bis zum Bundesverwaltungsgericht, dass es dann 2019 dem EuGH zur Prüfung vorgelegt hat. Die Entscheidung ist, EuGH steht aber noch aus. Darauf warten wir gerade. Das ist jetzt quasi das neue Gesetz von 2015. Und während die deutsche Umsetzung noch beim EuGH liegt, sitzen die quasi schon wieder da und sagen, alles klar, direkt noch eine Kugel rein, jetzt machen wir von der EU-Kommission her wieder eine neue Richtung. Notorisch, sie sind notorisch. Kommen wir zu den Facebook-Files.
Gott sei Dank haben die sich nicht schon vor drei Monaten umbenannt.
Ich glaube, man kann Facebook auch weiter Facebook nennen. Ich weiß auch überhaupt nicht, ja, jetzt benennt er da sein Unternehmen um. Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, warum. Wer will irgendeinen Grund haben? Willst du da eine Vision entwickeln?
Google heißt ja auch immer noch Google, obwohl sie nicht mehr Google heißt.
Aber 99% der Suchergebnisse speisen sich aus dem Alphabet.
Oh, nicht mehr lange, dann kommen die, speisen die sich alle aus Facebook.
Okay, dann gibt es die Whistleblowerin Frances Horgan, die ja im Prinzip, also es lässt sich zusammenfassen, das was sie der Öffentlichkeit sagt, ist ja einfach nur, dass Facebook Kenntnis hat von seinen schädigenden Effekten auf die Gesellschaft und trotz dieser Kenntnis quasi weiter diese Schäden in Kauf nimmt.
Also Schäden für die Demokratie oder Schäden auch für Jugendliche, all diese ganzen blaseninduzierten Probleme, die die sozialen Netzwerke mit sich bringen.
So, und dann gibt es irgendwie die Zusammenfassung dessen, was jetzt rauskommt. Jetzt gibt es irgendwie ein Konsortium oder eine Gruppe von Veröffentlichungen, die diese Facebook-Files bekommen haben, wo man im Prinzip sagen kann, ja, das ist so der Rest, der noch übrig ist. Die ursprüngliche Veröffentlichung war ja von der Washington Post mit Francis Horgan zusammen, wo sie eigentlich noch anonym war. Und dann hat sie sich irgendwann benannt. Was geht daraus hervor aus diesen Facebook-Files? Also erstens, Facebook war sich seiner Risiken und Nebenwirkungen immer bewusst. Das wäre jetzt auch wirklich überraschend, wenn sie das nicht mitbekommen hätten. Dann sagen sie, okay, dass der Mark Zuckerberg die Öffentlichkeit belogen hat. Und Zuckerberg hat unter Eid vor dem US-Senat gesagt, dass Milliarden Menschen die verschiedenen Plattformen nutzen und alle gleich sind. Aber manche Nutzerinnen und Nutzer werden mit dem Programm X-Check irgendwie mit Ausnahmen versehen. Also prominente Menschen, die Hausregeln brechen dürfen, ohne dafür sanktioniert zu werden. Wie zum Beispiel Donald Trump oder hier der Fußballer Neymar, der offenbar in einem Livestream den Klarnamen und Nacktbilder einer Frau gezeigt hat, die ihm eine Vergewaltigung vorführt. Okay, ich weiß schon, warum ich nicht auf diesem Facebook bin. Genau, dass er da quasi, dass sie eben nicht für alle Menschen die gleichen Regeln anwenden und nicht nur aus Versehen, nicht für alle Menschen die gleichen Regeln anwenden, sondern institutionalisiert für manche Menschen nicht die gleichen Regeln anwenden. Auch das, was Twitter ja zum Beispiel auch in dieser Diskussion um Trump irgendwann zugegeben hat und auch institutionalisiert hat. Die haben ja dann auch irgendwann gesagt, ja, wir haben Regeln, aber wenn du, was weiß ich, der US-Präsident bist, dann gelten die nicht mehr notwendigerweise für dich. Und die Argumentation, die sie dafür vorgetragen haben, war ja, okay, das ist nun mal der US-Präsident und das muss ja auch irgendwie der Nachwelt erhalten bleiben. Instagram kann der mentalen Gesundheit von Teenagern schaden. Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, wenn du einfach nur einmal Instagram aufmachst, siehst du das sofort. Ein Drittel der Mädchen, die sich unwohl in ihrem Körper fühlen, geht es schlechter, wenn sie Instagram nutzen. Mir geht es auch schlecht, wenn ich Instagram nutze. Also wenn du dir anschaust, was Menschen da für eine Scheinwelt irgendwie schaffen, mit diesen Filtern und die du den ganzen Tag nur damit beschäftigst, sich selber zu fotografieren. Also dass das irgendwie keine gesunden Konsequenzen hat, insbesondere für Teenager, ist halt naheliegend. Und da haben sie eben auch mehrere interne Studien zu, die ihnen das ganz klar zeigen. Dass sie also eine Gefahr für das Selbstwertgefühl sind, Depressionen auslösen und Suizidgedanken hervorrufen können. Auch das ist kein großes Geheimnis. Das Krasse ist, dass Facebook diese Dinge seit Jahren intern kennt. Und trotzdem ist ein konkretes Ziel von Facebook, auch das sehr verständlich, dass sie Kinder für sich gewinnen wollen. Ich meine, das war der Grund, dass die Facebook-Bevölkerung jedes Jahr um ein Jahr altert. Das sind die Gründe, warum sie sich hier was wie WhatsApp und Instagram gekauft haben, um eben diese Leute bei sich zu halten. Und sie sorgen, dass irgendwie Snapchat und TikTok in die Leute wegnehmen. Also zielen die natürlich spezifisch auf Teenager. Dann wollen sie irgendwie problematische Inhalte automatisch filtern. Das gelingt ihnen natürlich nicht, und zwar in beide Richtungen nicht. Also Alpha-Fehler, Beta-Fehler. Nachrichten, die keine Hassnachrichten sind, werden gelöscht. Dann haben sie natürlich einen US-Fokus. Also ich meine, welche Effekte Facebook in den USA hat, interessiert Facebook natürlich um einiges mehr als von irgendwelchen Ländern, die Donald Trump auf der Karte nicht finden kann. Auch das ist natürlich durchaus ein Problem. Und selbstverständlich sind sie eben primär Profit ausgerichtet, was jetzt auch nicht überraschend ist. Ich denke, das Entscheidende hier ist, was jetzt wirklich Whistleblowing ist, inhaltlich kommt da in meinen Augen nichts Neues mehr. Also alle diese Phänomene sind ja durchaus bekannt. Der Teil, der jetzt nochmal relevant wird, ist, und das kann eben hier die Frances Horgen eben gut herausbringen, was wusste Facebook wann und welche dem entgegenstehenden Entscheidungen haben sie noch getroffen? Und da wird Facebook natürlich nicht besonders gut bei rumkommen, weil natürlich wussten die all das. Das wusste ja jeder andere auch.
Die Argumentation würde mich auf jeden Fall mal interessieren, wenn sie versuchen, das anders darzustellen. Labern die ganze Zeit von einem allwissenden Müllhaltensystem. Aber das, was in ihrem eigenen System passiert, wo sie alle Algorithmen kontrollieren und wo genau das das Ding ist, womit sie ihr Geld machen, ausgerechnet das sollen sie nicht verstehen, das glaubt ihnen noch keiner.
Moment, hier sagte der, nur irgendwie diese Facebooks künstliche Intelligenz, der schreibt hier in diesem Weiß-Artikel, diese Zuckerberg-Ansprache wurde wohl auch irgendwie über Facebook gestreamt. Und die Empfehlungen darunter sind, also er sagt, 19.000 Leute haben diese Zuckerberg-Übertragung geschaut. Und der Algorithmus von Facebook hat, darunter steht dann andere Live-Videos für dich. Und hat irgendwie empfohlen, es gäbe also einmal ein Video von einer Latina, die einen kleinen Menschen dominiert und den Bauch leckt. Und ein Video-Livestream. Und zwar eine computergenerierte Animation von zwei Männern, die sich gegenseitig ficken. Das sind Facebook.
Zu ihrer eigenen Pilot.
Zu ihrer eigenen Produktankündigung.
Das sind alles legitive Inhalte. Das ist alles okay. Aber ich hätte jetzt so gedacht... Das zeigt halt, das illustriert halt sehr schön, dass die auf jeden Fall mit ihren Empfehlungen immer bemüht sind, dass du auf der Plattform bleibst. Und noch was Spannendes findest, falls dich die Produktankündigungen nicht interessiert, kannst du hier irgendwelchen... Oh Mann, die hat Land echt nicht im Griff. Kommen wir zu einer weniger schönen Geschichte, die vielleicht gar nicht so viel mit Netzpolitik zu tun hat.
Doch, auch.
Wir haben uns vor... wie lange ist das jetzt her? Vielleicht vor zwei Jahren oder so? Ja, sagen wir also mit... oder ich selber mach das ja auch immer wieder mit Hatern auseinandergesetzt.
Drei Jahre ist das her.
Drei Jahre?
Drei Jahre, LNP 265. Und da war von den Drachengames die Rege.
Genau, und da ging es ja... das war doch eigentlich Auslöser, war so eine Böhmermann und mehreren Leuten, so eine Recherche, also im Prinzip über Hater im Internet, die sich als Trolle bezeichnen und diesen Namen selbstverständlich nicht verdient haben. Und ein besonders tragisches Phänomen, das sich zwischenzeitlich auch wieder aus den Augen verloren hatte, muss ich zugeben, betrifft den Drachenlord, einen YouTuber, der irgendwo in der, ist das in der Pfalz oder was, wo der wohnt? Ich weiß es noch nicht mal. Einen YouTuber. Und der wird sehr ausführlich belagert und belästigt, nicht nur im Netz, sondern auch regelmäßig vor seiner eigenen Haustür. Und dass diese Zusammenrottung von Menschen, die dann dort sind, um ihn irgendwie zu einer Handlung zu provozieren, um sich dann daran zu ergötzen, dass der Mensch halt die Nerven verliert, das bezeichnen die als Drachengame und das machen sie seit sehr vielen Jahren. Und das ist eine absolut ekelhafte Sache, weil unabhängig davon, ob einem jetzt die Inhalte von dem Drachenlord gefallen oder nicht, ist das Internet ja groß genug, um sich irgendetwas anderes anzuschauen. Und es ist sehr, sehr erkenntlich, sagen wir mal, dass die diesen Menschen längst, wie übrigens jede andere Zielperson von Mobbing, wenn man das lange genug durchhält, auch an den Punkt haben, dass der nicht mehr in der Lage ist, dem noch irgendwas Sinnvolles entgegenzusetzen, weil es ja auch nichts Sinnvolles gibt, was man dem entgegensetzen kann, sodass sie den halt auch sehr gezielt an die Grenze gebracht haben, dass er gewalttätig wurde. Und das offenbar auch mehrmals. Ich habe jetzt, wie gesagt, diesen Fall nicht mehr so weiterverfolgt, aber der war offenbar inzwischen vorbestraft wegen Körperverletzung. Und jetzt sind da wohl, wenn ich diesen Fall richtig verstanden habe, ging es da jetzt konkret um Medizinstudenten. Also weiß man auch, welche gesellschaftliche Stellung Medizinstudenten haben, die irgendwie angetrunken, dann da zu dessen Haus gegangen sind, den provoziert haben und in diesem Video sogar noch sagen, jawohl Alter, jetzt kommt er, jetzt bringen wir ihn in den Knast. Und die es quasi darauf angelegt haben, den zu provozieren, damit er sie angreift, damit sie ihn anzeigen können, damit er in den Knast wandert, weil er eben vorbestraft ist. So gestaltet sich das jetzt offenbar. So, jetzt fand da eben eine Gerichtsverhandlung statt. Und die Richterin macht etwas, was sehr häufig mit Mobbing-Opfern getan wird. Und sagt ihm, sie wäre ja hier bereit, das Verfahren einzustellen, so ungefähr, oder eine Strafmilderung in Aussicht zu stellen. Wenn er denn seine YouTube-Aktivitäten einstellen würde, würdet ihr auch denken, entschuldige mal bitte. Also jeder Mensch kann in dieses Scheiß YouTube reinlabern, was er möchte. Und so lange das nicht strafrechtlich relevant ist, ist das vollkommen in Ordnung. Noch dazu ist das für diesen Drachenlord sein Einkommen. Der hat eben auch irgendwie einen Supporterkanal und Werbeeinnahmen. Und das ist quasi seine Möglichkeit, Geld zu verdienen. Und die Richterin sagt dem, ja pass mal auf, das was du da machst, ist ja offenbar für viele Menschen eine Provokation, die dann bei dir vor der Haustür rumlungern und dich irgendwie halt an den Rand des Wahnsinns treiben. Hör doch mal auf damit, du bist da selber schuld.
Das ist wirklich... Das ist so ein bisschen das Äquivalent, Vergewaltigungsopfern irgendwie ihre Kleidung vorzuwerfen.
Exakt. Und das ist genau das. Und das ist, jeder und jede von uns kennt ja wahrscheinlich auch Fälle von Mobbing in der Schule. Und das ist ja durchaus auch ein Muster, dass dann den Leuten eben gesagt wird, so dass die früher oder später vom Lehrer oder von der Lehrerin so sinngemäß gesagt kriegen, hör mal, weisse, dann sei doch auch mal nicht so scheiße, dann ärgern dich die anderen Kinder auch nicht mehr. Um deinem Selbstwert noch so den letzten Stich zu geben. Ja, End vom Lied ist, unter anderem da er eben gesagt hat, ja hier, nee, das ist keine Option für ihn, seine YouTube-Aktivitäten einzustellen, wo ich auch ganz ehrlich sagen muss, also das finde ich unerhört von dieser Richterin, das überhaupt in Erwägung zu ziehen. Und so wie das aussieht, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, wurde er jetzt zu zwei Jahren verurteilt. Die Leute, die ihn dahin getrieben haben, in diese Gewalt, die das gezielt mit ihm getan haben, dass er irgendwann halt gewalttätig wird und das mit dem Ziel gemacht haben, ihn in den Knast zu bringen, feiern sich jetzt irgendwie als so eine Art Helden des Antifaschismus oder so, weil er irgendwann wohl auch in seinen, weiß nicht wie viele Stunden der Typ da jeden Tag streamt, mal eine ausländerfeindliche Äußerung oder einen abwertenden Begriff verwendet hat, was ich nicht entschuldigen möchte, aber was jetzt üblicherweise, sage ich mal, nicht darin mündet, dass Menschen über Monate und Jahre belagert werden und man sich darauf anlegt, dass sie in den Knast kommen. Ich meine, wenn ihr das irgendwie für einen antifaschistischen Kampf haltet, dann macht das doch von mir aus bei Björn Höcke mal. Mal gucken, wie lange ihr da vor der Tür rumlungert. Ich meine, der ist ähnlich. Du kannst dir Gegner suchen oder Opfer. Und die haben sich sehr klar einen Opfer gesucht. Und das ist in meinen Augen ein absoluter Justizskandal, was mit diesem Menschen da getan wird. Erstens, dass das zugelassen wird. Der wohnt in einem winzig kleinen Dorf. Die Polizei ist natürlich genervt.
Auch die Anwohner seit Jahren.
Die Anwohner sind genervt, haben die ganze Zeit die Leute da. Und wie gesagt, der Typ hat jetzt lange keinen souveränen Umgang mehr damit. Und entsprechend haben die natürlich dann auch irgendwann die Nachbarn gesagt, ja, wäre vielleicht auch cool, wenn du einfach mal was anderes machen würdest. Aber, Alter, was für ein... Also das ist wirklich sowas von ekelhaft. Das ist wirklich schlimm.
Ja, das Schlimmste daran ist halt einfach, und das kann einen auch irgendwie frustrieren, insbesondere wenn sie das jetzt wieder im Namen des Antifaschismus auch noch tun, wie niedrig die Leute doch sind. Also wie einfach, die sich ihr Leben machen und einfach immer schön nach unten treten, immer auf die Schwächeren, immer schön sich selber geiler fühlen, obwohl man eigentlich selber wahrscheinlich ein total ungeiles Leben führt, aber das natürlich sich selbst nicht zugestehen möchte oder nichts auch Positives daran ändern möchte. So, nee, dann nimmt man sich so ein Opfer, dann feiert man sich da im Netz in so einen Rausch, so, ah, jetzt haben wir ja alle hier gegenseitig ein Opfer, und dann steigert man sich auch so schnell rein, bis man diesen ganzen Unsinn von Ausreden auch noch wirklich glaubt. Und ja, ob das jetzt irgendwie dieses Corona-Leugner-Schwurbeltum ist mit diesen Anti-Wachsern und so weiter, die einfach im Prinzip genau das gleiche machen, ja, einfach sich schön weit weg von der Realität entfernen und sich dann auch einfach noch radikalisieren und sich dabei auch noch als Freiheitskämpfer, ja, und Diktatoren schlechter feiern und fühlen, wofür es einfach keinerlei Anhaltspunkte gibt. Einerseits mangels der Diktatoren und andererseits mangels auch eines validen Kampfes dagegen. Es ist halt einfach billig und schlecht und diese Leute sollten sich einfach mal was schämen. Nur es sind Massen, es sind wirklich viele und das ist irgendwie auch schon etwas, wo man auch immer wieder mal feststellen muss, klar, wir halten uns alle für total zivilisiert und gebildet und modern und Deutschland und überhaupt und so. Das mag für weite Teile der Gesellschaft auch gelten, aber die Verrohung steht eigentlich jeden Tag schon auf der Straße, um im Taxi abgeholt zu werden. Das geht alles sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schnell. Die Leute vergessen sehr schnell ihre Prinzipien und ihre angeblichen, ihren moral high ground, auf dem sie sich irgendwie fühlen. In dem Moment, wo sie irgendwie selber austeilen können und anderen Leuten in irgendeiner Form bereit sind, dann auch das zu entziehen, was für sie selber vollkommen selbstverständlich ist. Anerkennung zu haben, Liebe zu erfahren, dabei zu sein, würdiges Leben zu führen. Und sie sehen es auch einfach gar nicht, dass sie sich hier von so einer kollektiven Idiotie instrumentalisieren lassen, der sie selber Teil sind.
Ich frag mich halt, wie du ernsthaft, wenn du den Typen siehst, auf die Idee kommen kannst, dass der noch nicht genug hätte und du da noch irgendwie was zu beitragen musst.
Ja, warum werden Obdachlose überfallen? Also ich meine, es trifft ja immer schon die Schwächsten. Und das kann man sich ja genauso wenig vorstellen. Und es sind die Flüchtlinge, die sozusagen alles verloren haben, die dann irgendwie auch nochmal oben einen drauf bekommen müssen. Und das ist eigentlich immer dasselbe Ding. Und Leute, die etabliert sind und stark rüberkommen und Geld haben und Beziehungen haben, denen passiert sowas halt nicht. Und natürlich fahren die jetzt irgendwie nicht zu Herrn Höcke, auch wenn man vielleicht mal seine Adresse als die neue Wohnadresse vom Drachenlord rausgeben könnte. Da wäre ich wirklich mal gespannt. Dann treffen die Hater mal richtig auf die Hater.
Also kann ich dir sagen, warum man sich dem Anwesen von Höcke wahrscheinlich lieber nicht nähert, weil er wahrscheinlich sofort irgendwie in hooligan Trupp bereit steht, um dir auf die Fresse zu hauen. Also ich muss mich da jetzt noch mal einlesen, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, hat die Staatsanwältin sogar jetzt auch noch Berufungen angekündigt, weil sie die Strafe nicht gut genug findet. Er hätte sich gerne eine höhere Strafe für den Drachenlord gewünscht.
Ist sie nicht diejenige, die das umsetzt?
Nee, es ist Richterin, die das macht.
Ach so, ich habe es verwechselt. Staatsanwälte möchte noch mehr drauf haben.
Sie möchte gerne noch mehr drauf haben. Also du fragst dich wirklich, was haben die denn da? Also es ist wirklich irre. Es gibt ein Video, in dem er das auch mal sagt. Ich glaube wirklich, das, was sie dem angetan haben, das hält halt kein Mensch aus. Und auch wenn ich jetzt sicherlich nicht die Inhalte irgendwie besonders interessant oder erstrebenswert finde, die der verbreitet, begnüge ich mich einfach tagtäglich mit der Option, irgendwas anderes zu gucken. Und so sehe ich wirklich nicht, was die über die Jahre mit dem gemacht haben. Du erinnerst dich hier dieser, wie heißt die nochmal, diese Imp und Dorian, dieser Arschlöcher da. Die hatten dem ja dann irgendwie eine Frau dahingeschickt, die dann Tateilswesen den verliebt und dann hat der im Livestream einen Heiratsantrag gemacht. Und in dem Moment hat sie dann gesagt, du bist irgendwie ein hässlicher Wichser, du bist der Ekelhafteste, den ich kenne. Und dann haben sie sich darüber kaputt gelacht, dass sie den verarscht hatten. Weißt du, ich mein, das ist einfach, das ist alles so unterirdisch.
So unterirdisch und unwürdig und verachtenswürdig, was die Leute machen. Das geht gar nicht mehr.
Das ist so niedrig, ey. Und ich frage mich wirklich, was denn so Menschen los ist, die dann irgendwie auch noch da sitzen und quasi als eine Aufwertung ihrer selbst oder als witzig oder sowas wahrnehmen. Also wirklich echt kranker Shit.
Dafür fehlt uns leider jetzt die intellektuelle Kraft, das noch zu verstehen.
Naja, Impfpässe sind gefälscht im Umlauf. Also das ist irgendwie noch nicht so ganz klar, was da los ist. Also die italienische Nutzer sind irgendwie im Besitz von Impfpässen, die also sehr offensichtlich nicht echt sein können. Irgendwie ein gültiges Impfzertifikat für Adolf Hitler geboren am 1.1.1900. Offenbar ist mindestens einer oder mehrere geheime Schlüssel abhanden gekommen, mit denen andere in der Lage waren, quasi dann beliebige Impfpässe auszustellen. Es ist noch nicht ganz klar, wie das passiert ist. Ich hätte da mehrere Hypothesen, aber es ist offenbar geschehen. Wir werden sicherlich auch noch erfahren, wie genau das passiert ist. Das Spannende ist jetzt, wie gehst du jetzt damit um? Das war etwas, was wir hier auch in der Sendung behandelt haben, dass du dich auf jeden Fall auf diesen Fall vorbereiten musst, wenn du eine PKI baust.
Also Public Key Infrastruktur.
Genau, also eine Zertifikatsinfrastruktur, mit der ja diese Dinger signiert werden. Die Zertifikatsignaturen sind ja das, was den gültigen vom ungültigen Impfpass unterscheidet. Und die Hierarchie dahinter ist so ungefähr, es gibt dann eine EU-Ebene, dann gibt es mehrere Mitgliedstaaten und die können dann jeweils immer noch mal die Genehmigung zum Signieren von Zertifikaten delegieren. Und dann hast du quasi eine Kette, die hochgeht, was weiß ich, bis auf die Ebene deines Staates oder vielleicht sogar bis auf die Ebene der EU, je nachdem, was du jetzt gerade verifizierst, ob du im eigenen Land oder im Ausland usw. Das wird dann kompliziert, aber grundsätzlich ist es immer nur das Prüfen einer Signaturkette. Dass dir ein Signaturzertifikat oder dir geheime Schlüssel davon abhanden kommt, das musst du einplanen. Und die Kontingenzpläne, die du dafür hast, sind folgende. Erstens könnte es sein, ein einzelner Impfpass wird ausgestellt, der unberechtigt ist. Dann könntest du den spezifischen einen Impfpass revoken, also zurückrufen. Dafür hast du eine CRL, eine Certificate Revocation List. Da haust du die Prüf-Summen von ungültigen Zertifikaten rein und signierst die wieder, mit denen du die Aussage triffst, ja, ich hab mal gesagt, dass der gültig ist, für sechs Monate oder ein Jahr. Aber hiermit sage ich, dass das nicht mehr der Fall ist. Die nächste Möglichkeit ist, wenn dir das hier passiert, dass du dann eben einzelne Zertifikate, diese Zertifikate, die gefälschte unterschrieben haben, ungültig machst. Also du sagst nicht nur dieser eine Impfpass ist ungültig, sondern alle, die mit diesem Zertifikat signiert wurden. Und dafür musst du aber natürlich dann dafür sorgen, dass dieses Signatur-Zertifikat möglichst häufig sich wechselt. Mir ist nicht ganz klar, was die hier gemacht haben. Und ich befürchte, dass sie die vielleicht doch nicht so oft gewechselt haben oder so viele unterschiedliche genommen haben. Jedenfalls war es zu Beginn des Launches dieser Greenpass-Infrastruktur in Deutschland und Europa so, dass sie nicht einen spezifischen Revocation-Prozess überhaupt hatten. Und vor allem, weil sie den nicht haben, haben sie jetzt das Problem, dass zwar die italienische Nachrichtenagentur sagt, dass sie diese geheimen Schlüsse, mit denen das gefälschte Zertifikat erstellt wurde, zurückgerufen haben. Das heißt, eben alle anderen, die damit signiert wurden, sind jetzt auch ungültig, sagen aber nicht, wie viele das sind. Und gleichzeitig wird aber jetzt in der deutschen COFPASS-Check-App, zumindest Zeitpunkt gestern, das Zertifikat noch als gültig angezeigt. Ja, also es sieht offenbar jetzt also danach aus, dass die nicht so wirklich sich darüber Gedanken gemacht haben, wie diese Revocation halt gut läuft. Und vor allem das nicht vereinheitlicht haben. Das war auch mein Eindruck aus den Gesprächen damals, als der ganze Kram online ging. Wie groß der Schaden jetzt ist, werden wir noch sehen. Aber dieser Fall, dass der eintreten würde, muss vorgesehen sein. Du darfst es nicht so bauen, dass du davon ausgehst, dass dir sowas nicht passiert. Und ich denke, die Bewertungsdimension ist jetzt, wie viele Impfpässe müssen sie jetzt ungültig machen, weil sie mit diesem offensichtlich kompromittierten Zertifikat signiert wurden. Und damit leider jetzt als ungültig zu betrachten sind, unabhängig davon, ob sie tatsächlich ungültig sind oder vor einem potenziellen Diebstahl, oder Abhandenkommen oder Kompromittierung dieses Schlüssels signiert wurden. Muss man mal sehen, wie das läuft. Es wird auf jeden Fall spannend zu erfahren, wie die Angreifer an diese Keys gekommen sind. Das sollte eigentlich natürlich nicht möglich sein. Und dann mal gucken, wie viele sie jetzt ungültig machen müssen deshalb.
Wir hatten ja hier, als diese ganze Impfpass-Diskussion war, mal so ein bisschen im Kopf durchgerechnet, wie lange das jetzt dauert, das alles auszurollen etc. Und sind ja da erstmal auf sehr lange Zeiträume gekommen. Und dann ging ja alles ganz schnell.
Genau, das ging aber schnell, weil sie den Signaturteil im Prinzip aufs Server bewegt haben und nicht den Apotheken eigenes Schlüsselmaterial gegeben haben. Und dann hatten sie ja auch noch quasi die Authentifizierung auf der Ebene schwach gemacht, wo es dann eben ja auch noch die Demonstrationen gab, dass man sich relativ einfach als Apotheke registrieren konnte.
Genau, also es ist Zeit gespart worden, indem man einfach nicht ausreichend nachgedacht hat, welche Konsequenzen die Struktur hat, die man da ausrollt. Und das erklärt es ein wenig, macht es aber nicht besser. Das ist einfach ein Problem, zumal ja eben auch in der ganzen Debatte, wir jetzt, jetzt haben wir, jetzt stehen wir vor der vierten Welle oder wir stehen mittendrin, kann man sagen. Es sind halt viele nicht geimpft. Wir haben teilweise 2G-Systematiken, wo dann gesagt wird, na ja, aber bei 2G können ja nur Geimpfte sein. Aber wenn dann eben dieses Impfpass-Regime dann so lax ist, ist das natürlich dann auch eine akute Gefährdung der Leute. Und das ist halt das, was ich nicht so richtig verstehen kann. Dass wenn man jetzt wirklich schon sagt, ok, alles klar, auf der Basis versuchen wir zumindest den Teil, der bereit ist, sich für sich und andere zu schützen, auch die Freiheiten wiederzugeben, dass das dann dadurch torpediert wird, dass das einfach technisch nicht ordentlich umgesetzt wird, abgesehen davon, dass, ich weiß nicht, welche Erfahrungen du gemacht hast, ohnehin diese ganzen Impfpässe so lax geprüft werden, wenn überhaupt. Also ich war jetzt bei verschiedensten Veranstaltungen und hab alles gesehen von, keiner wollte was sehen, man war zufrieden, wenn man irgendwas QR-Code-artiges in der Hand hatte. Also ich hab sogar schon meinen laminierten QR-Code einfach nur in der Luft gewädelt, ohne weitere Erklärungen, ohne dass da ein Name drauf steht. Also lesbar, für Menschen lesbar. Dann halt diese Display-Scroller, die sie zumindest noch irgendwie sehen wollen, dass das jetzt auch wirklich eine App ist, aber wessen QR-Code da angezeigt wird, dann auch nicht interessiert. Und selten wird dann mal gescannt. Und dann gibt's halt noch die Leute, die scannen, aber dann eben die Daten nicht überprüfen. Ich würde mal fast sagen, derzeit in 80 bis 90 Prozent der Fälle würde man sogar noch mit irgendeinem QR-Code oder gar keinem QR-Code durchkommen.
Das habe ich aber damals zum Launch dieses Dings im ZDF-Interview gesagt. Habe ich gesagt, niemand wird sich Stress machen bei der Prüfung dieser Impfpässe. In diesem Live-Interview bin ich kurz daran vorbeigeschrammt, die reißen sich doch hier nicht mit ihnen Stress ein oder sowas. Das ist genau. Der Punkt. Niemand hat ein Interesse an der genauen Prüfung dieser Zertifikate. Das war immer meine Vorhersage und das ist ja auch klar. Ich glaube, ein-, zweimal bin ich in ein Hotel eingecheckt. Und da war dann, weil sie ja eh dann quasi den Namen sehen beim Check-In. Ich glaube, ein einziges Mal wurde ich auch tatsächlich nach dem Personalausweis noch dazu gefragt. Aber ja, ich bin jetzt auch nicht, also ich würde immer noch sagen, das ist wahrscheinlich ganz gut, dass es nicht so krass überprüft wird, weil die, wenn es anders wäre, wäre das glaube ich auch, würde das zu sehr viel Unmut führen. Aber weißt du, was sehr unterhaltsam ist, Tim? Du kannst, ich habe jetzt hier kürzlich ein neues Telefon gehabt, ja, und dann musste ich irgendwie umziehen. Und da habe ich gesehen, dass in der Corona-Warn-App jetzt mein Impf-Zertifikat nicht mit umgezogen ist. Ja, und weißt du, was ich dann gemacht habe? Da habe ich einfach mein altes Telefon genommen, habe gesagt, hier zeige ich mal Impf-Zertifikat an, habe das neue Telefon genommen und habe gesagt, importier mal. Und dann hat er natürlich mein Impf-Zertifikat einfach übernommen. Das heißt, der Prozess, zeige ich mal dein Impf-Zertifikat, ich scanne mal den QR-Code, das ist im Prinzip alles, was du brauchst, um jemand anders sein Impf-Zertifikat zu klauen.
Wo da natürlich ein anderer Name dran steht.
Ja genau, was ja aber wiederum keine Sau interessiert. Und die Verwirrung mit COFPASS und COFPASS-Check ist der Gestalt, dass ein Freund von mir, der eine Kneipe betreibt, dann irgendwie so, und jetzt nicht, sage ich mal, der digital native ist, der hat sich quasi auch so eine App runtergeladen und rief mich nach ein paar Stunden an und sagte, ey Linus, diese ganzen Impfpässe, die werden da drin gespeichert. Und ich sagte, nee, das kann nicht sein. Das kann nicht sein, dass die gespeichert werden.
Er hat die alle importiert.
Und er sagte, das kann doch nicht sein, Datenschutz. Dieser Prozess, den hat halt niemand verstanden. Niemand hat das verstanden. Ich hab's ja auch mal erklärt. Ich hab's ja öfter mal erklärt. Ich muss jetzt dazu sagen, ich finde, dass du einfach wirklich, dass der Prozess, dass du wirklich so ein angezeigtes Zertifikat trotzdem einfach sofort wieder importieren kannst, ich finde, das hätte man anders machen sollen. Da hätte man zumindest noch in den QR-Code einfach mit reinschreiben können. Ich zeige das hier gerade an zur Verifikation, damit jetzt zumindest irgendwie eine Standard-App nicht sofort diesen Impfpass auch dann importiert. Damit ist das Problem nicht aus der Welt, weil du relativ simpel eine bauen kannst, die es trotzdem macht, und du kannst sie ja auch einfach kopieren und so weiter. Aber das ist eben auch nun mal die Eigenschaft des Impfausweises wie jeder andere auch. Das wäre bei dem Gelben genauso. Der ist nichts wert ohne einen Vergleich mit dem Personalausweis und so weiter und so fort. Alles hundertmal erklärt. Und es ist klar, dass es niemand ordentlich macht. Und entsprechend kannst du wahrscheinlich auch sagen, ja gut, dann sind jetzt halt auch noch gefälscht im Umlauf. Hauptsache Telekom und SAP haben ihre Millionen kassiert. Ich meine, ich bleibe ja dabei, dass ich jetzt insgesamt kein großer Fan der Gesamtidee Impfpasskontrolle bin. Gleichzeitig mich gestern auch nochmal darüber unterhalten. Will man jetzt diesen kalten Impfzwang, will man darauf setzen, dass man sagt, ihr kommt jetzt irgendwo nicht mehr rein, was letztendlich auch Reaktanz erhöht und die Motivation, sich gefälschte Impfpässe zu holen. Realistisch ist das Schlimmste, was dir passiert, wenn du jetzt mit dem Impfpass vom Kumpel versuchst, in irgendein Restaurant zu kommen. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Person, die da vorne steht, bei der du dann sagst, ich bin nun mal der Markus, haste nicht gesehen, ich hab halt meinen Ausweis nicht dabei, tut mir leid, dass die sagt, okay, da musst du jetzt gehen. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist eh schon weit unter 1%. Und wenn du an diese 1% an Leuten gerätst, die dann ernsthaft sagen, geh bitte, dann bin ich mal gespannt, wie viel Prozent von denen auch noch sagen würden, oh mein Gott, das ist hier ein Enttäuschungsversuch, ich ruf die Bullen. Und dann ist noch die Frage, ob es überhaupt strafbar ist, einen falschen Impfpass zu zeigen oder nicht.
Und ob das nachgewiesen werden kann, dass das jetzt absichtlich geschehen ist in dem Moment, ja, ne, habe ich falsch verstanden.
Genau, ach Mist, habe ich das falsche Handy eingesteckt. Ich bin ja gar nicht geimpft. Und jetzt wäre die andere Frage, wenn du jetzt sagst, du willst die Impfquote erhöhen, kannst du halt mit negativen Anreizen das versuchen. Du kannst aber auch positive Anreize geben, wie wir hier gescherzt haben mit der Bratwurst. Da haben wir uns noch drüber lustig gemacht, weil wir jederzeit lieber die Impfung als die Bratwurst genommen hätten. Jetzt gibt es Leute, die zweifeln, wie diesen Fußballer, der dieser Kimmich oder wie der heißt. Sehr interessant, klingt halt erst mal komisch, aber wenn du einfach sagst, alles klar, hier kriegst du noch ein Fuffi zur Impfung, was meinst du, wie viele Leute das machen würden? Und ich glaube, dass du damit halt, ich meine, dann hast du die Querdenker, die dann sagen, ja, die Menschenversuche 50 Euro ist viel zu wenig für einen Menschenversuch, aber immerhin kriegst du mal Geld für deinen Menschenversuch. Muss man doch auch mal positiv sehen. Und diese Diktaturvorstellungen, die dann da sind, denen hätte man halt auch sehr viel Wind aus dem Segel nehmen können, wenn man eben mehr auf positive Anreize gesetzt hätte als auf negative.
Ja, es ist nämlich selten, dass in Diktaturen die Leute für ihre Folter auch noch bezahlt werden.
Ja, allerdings in einer GmbH-Diktatur natürlich dann schon. Okay, dann haben die Reporter ohne Grenzen noch eine Klage eingereicht oder direkt mehrere. Und zwar die Reporter ohne Grenzen als Vereinigung mit Investigativjournalistinnen und Journalisten und dem Whistleblower-Netzwerk klagen sie gegen die neuen Staatstrojaner Befugnisse für Geheimdienste. Die wurden ja im Juni quasi verabschiedet, wo gesagt wird, jetzt haben alle Nachrichtendienste die Möglichkeit mittels Space-Software in Smartphones und Computer einzudringen und verschlüsselte Nachrichten abzuhören. Also Staatstrojaner für Geheimdienste. Wichtig, immer im Hinterkopf behalten, der Unterschied zwischen Polizei und Geheimdiensten ist, Polizei muss sich potenziell irgendwann einmal für den Einsatz rechtfertigen und sammelt Beweise gegen dich. Und der Geheimdienst muss sich im Zweifelsfall nie rechtfertigen. Und damit hast du halt auch dann keine nennenswerten Möglichkeiten zur Feststellung, dass die Maßnahme nicht rechtens war, die gegen dich ergriffen wurde. So, jetzt argumentieren Reporter ohne Grenzen, dass in dieser Ausweitung dieser Beflugnisse auf die Nachrichtendienste keinerlei Berücksichtigung von Journalistinnen und Journalistinnen ihren Quellen ist, die also damit auch Ziel solcher Maßnahmen werden können und dürfen. Und das ist natürlich ein schwerwiegender Eingriff in das Redaktionsgeheimnis. Und entsprechend klagen sie dagegen. Christian Mier, der Geschäftsführer von Reporter ohne Grenzen, sagte, dieses Gesetz ist auch ein Eingriff auf den Informantenschutz im digitalen Raum. Was auf den ersten Blick aussieht wie eine Nebensächlichkeit, kann große Konsequenzen für investigativ arbeitende Journalistinnen und Journalisten haben. Einmal mehr ziehen wir gegen ein Gesetz vor Gericht, das Sachverständige für verfassungswidrig erklärt haben und das dennoch über alt und ohne Rücksicht auf die Folgen für Journalismus und Pressefreiheit in Deutschland verabschiedet wurde. Hat er recht. Und kann man natürlich eigentlich hoffen, dass diese Klage durchaus Aussicht auf Erfolg hat, weil wenn du jetzt irgendwie die Befugnisse deiner Geheimdienste über die Pressefreiheit stellst, dann bist du halt wirklich ein bisschen weit gegangen.
Ja, gibt aber auch durchaus Leute, die das schon lange so sehen, dass dem so ist.
Aber jede einzelne Klage gegen Staatstrojanereinsatz ist eine wichtige und eine richtige. Und deswegen begrüße ich das sehr, dass hier die Reporter ohne Grenzen mit dem Whistleblower-Netzwerk sich gegen diese Sache zu wehrsetzen. Machen die ja auch nicht zum ersten Mal. Jetzt sind wir am Ende, Mitte nächster Woche. Ich schaue gerade schon in den Shop, er macht Fortschritte. Und da wird es dann schöne T-Shirts geben und Hoodies vielleicht auch. Können wir eigentlich auch mal anbieten. Den bestücken wir und dann könnt ihr so am 3. November abends, denke ich, mal schauen, ob ihr euch bekleiden möchtet, ob ihr Werbekunde bei uns werden möchtet.
Genau, dazu dann nächste Woche mehr von uns. Und zwischendurch wisst ihr, ihr könnt ja immer auf Twitter gucken. Entweder folgt da Linus, et Linuzifa, oder mir, et Tim Pritlove.
Oder dem Netzpolitik-Account, ME, unterstrich.
Bewerbe gerade unsere Twitter-Accounts.
Ja, ich möchte aber auch, dass mein Instagram-Account beworben wird.
Und wie ist der?
Ich hab nämlich ein Instagram-Account gemacht, ursprünglich einfach mal um sicherzustellen, dass mir den Platz da keiner wegnimmt. Aber ich war ein der großen Kunstwerke in Hamburg dieser Zeit. Kennst du diese Story? Das müssen wir eigentlich noch erzählen. Andy! Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das überhaupt behandelt hatten. Also die Geschichte geht so. Hamburg hat einen Innensenator. Dieser Innensenator heißt Andy Grote. Und der hat wohl auch irgendetwas getwittert, was eine sehr große Janusköpfigkeit zum Ausdruck gebracht hat. Und darauf hat jemand mit einem sehr kleinen Twitter-Account geantwortet. Andy, du bist so ein Pimmel.
Ein Pimmel.
Oder so ein Pimmel. Also eine Eins statt ein Ein. Und jetzt kann man, so die meisten Leute, haben dann die Größe, über so etwas hinwegzusehen. Aber manche Leute sind eben, ich glaube, das nennt man fragile Männlichkeit, reagieren bei so etwas sehr empfindlich. Aus welchem Grund auch immer. Und der Andy-Senator, der Innen-Senator Andy Grote von Hamburg, reagiert eben bei so etwas empfindlich. Und deswegen hat er dann einen Strafantrag wegen Beleidigung gestellt. Und da wollte natürlich dann die Polizei, die ihm ja untersteht, zeigen, dass sie ihre Arbeit richtig gut machen kann. Und haben dann eine Hausdurchsuchung anberaumt. In dem Fall dann der Freundin des Angezeigten auf der Suche nach dem Tatmittel. Als bräuchte man jetzt noch irgendwelche großen Beweise, dass dieser Mensch diesen Tweet abgesetzt hat. Also Hausdurchsuchung wegen eines Tweets. So, großes Gelächter und das hatte dann etwas zur Folge, was als Pimmelgate inzwischen fester Bestandteil des Wikipedia-Artikels zum Streisandeffekt ist. Nämlich, dass sich vorher niemand für den Pimmel von Andy Grote interessiert hat. Wirklich niemand, außer eben Andy Grote. Und dieses Interesse jetzt eigentlich die Hansestadt Hamburg geradezu in ihren Bann gezogen hat. Irgendjemand hat dann Aufkleber gedruckt. So kleine neongelbe Aufkleber rund, wo drauf steht Andy, du bist so ein Pimmel. Und die wurden in St. Pauli geklebt. An verschiedene Stellen im öffentlichen Raum. St. Pauli ist offenbar der Wohnort von Andy, was dazu geführt hat, dass er mit seiner Pimmel konfrontiert wurde. Die Polizei hat dann im Rahmen der Gefahrenabwehr diese Aufkleber abgemacht. Du hast einen Polizisten, der durch St. Pauli rennt. Und die Gefahrabwehren, die von diesen Aufklebern ausgeht.
Die unglaubliche, gefährliche, große Gefahr von Aufklebern.
Unglaublich.
Wo ja noch nicht mal sein voller Name drauf steht. Es könnte ja jetzt irgendwelche Andys sein.
Und dann war auch wieder, ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ich glaube, da war dann auch wieder Staatsschutz ermittelt gegen Unbekannt, irgendein Scheiß. Also wieder das komplette Programm. Dann hat die Rote Flora ein seit Jahrzehnten besetztes Theater in Hamburg am Schulterblatt. Zentrale Anlaufstelle der Hamburger Linken. Die haben so eine Plakatwand. Und sie haben auf diese Plakatwand, glaube ich zwei sogar, auf die linke haben sie dann so Theatervorhänge gemacht. So rechts und links und rot und oben drüber. Dann haben sie ganz oben drauf geschrieben Soko Wand und Farbe. Und quasi hinter dem Vorhang, der ja dann offen ist, klebte dann sehr groß ein neongelber Kreis. In dem drin stand Andy, du bist so ein Spimmel. Was quasi einfach dieser Aufkleber war, den sie dann eben in Plakatgröße an ihr Gebäude geklebt haben. Jetzt muss man dazu wieder die Geschichte der Soko Wand und Farbe kennen, die damals in der Hafenstraße einen Schriftzug an einem Haus entfernen wollte, wo irgendwie, was weiß ich, Bullen oder sowas stand. Das wollten die wegmachen. Deswegen ist dann die Soko Wand und Farbe mit einem Hubwagen angereist und rollen mit schwarzer Farbe und haben dann an diesem Haus irgendwie die Wörter weggemalt, die ihnen nicht gefallen haben. Woraufhin die Bewohner mit einem Gartenschlauch aus dem Fenster diese Farbe einfach wieder abgespült haben, weil die Polizei wasserlös nicht mitgebracht hat. Und zu guter Letzt hat dann die rüstige Bewohnerschaft der Hafenstraße dieser Sachbeschädigung, die ihr im Haus angedeihen sollte, entgegengewirkt durch den Wurf von Farbe. In diesem Fall allerdings nicht wasserlösliche Farbe, die dann also die Uniformen der Polizistinnen kleideten. Und du hattest dann, da gibt es einen sehr schönen Fernsehbeitrag für den suche ich auch noch mal raus, indem wir die Show notes, so eine Situation, wie dann eben oben die Hafenstraßebewohner ihr Haus sauber machen, wo die schwarze Farbe einfach runterläuft und unten die Polizisten stehen mit ihrem Wasser wieder und versuchen ihre Uniform sauber zu machen, was aber nicht von Erfolg gekrönt ist. Das ist der Hintergrund von dieser Überschrift Soko Wand und Farbe. Und du hast also jetzt diesen großen runden Aufkleber auf dem Plakat, der halt da schon dran anspielt und mit diesem Vorhang ja auch sehr, mit mehreren Anspielungen die Spiele eröffnet. Und was passiert? Es ist tatsächlich, gibt die Polizei sich die Blöße, da mit einer schwarzen Rolle hinzugehen und dieses Andy, du bist so ein Pimmel an der roten Flora zu übermalen, als polizeiliche Maßnahme. Konsequenz, nächsten Tag steht da mit Sprühfarbe wieder Andy, du bist so ein Pimmel. Polizei kommt wieder mit ihrer schwarzen Farbe und malt da wieder drüber und jetzt steht da eben Andy, du bist so ein Pimmel, tritt zurück und oben links steht Flora 3, Bullen 2, also der Spielstand. Wie kannst du dich als Innensenator so zum Gespött der Leute machen? Außerdem hängt in Hamburg in mehreren Plakatkästen irgendwie so eine, ja im Prinzip sieht das aus wie so eine Spiegeltimmel-Seite, nur statt Spiegel steht oben Pimmel. Auf dem Cover ist dann halt der Innensenator Andy Grote und der Mann lässt sich jetzt mit Anlauf seit inzwischen Monaten durch den Kakao ziehen und du fragst dich ernsthaft, ob der denn irgendein Verständnis hat davon, dass er sich damit gerade, also der macht sich halt wirklich, zum Pimmel macht er sich. Der macht sich echt zum Pimmel, wenn er einfach diesen blöden Tweet ignoriert hätte oder diese blöden Aufkleber oder das Ding an der Flora, aber nein, immer wieder drauf, immer wieder drauf. Und jetzt gibt es halt Menschen, die bezeichnen den Hals als Pimmel-Andy. Das würde ich mir jetzt nicht zu eigen machen, eine derartige Bezeichnung, aber da muss man echt sagen, vielleicht sollte der mal zu so einer Richterin gehen, die ihm dann sagt, ja Herr Grote, vielleicht hören sie einfach auf. Das ist auf jeden Fall, würde ich sagen, ein Fall von Mobbing, der halt echt einfach nur von ihm selber angeheizt wird. Das hat er sich selber zuzuschreiben.
Absolut. Ich hätte trotzdem ganz gerne diese Ausgabe von dem Magazin, dem ehemaligen Nachrichtenmagazin der Pimmel, weil da sind wirklich interessante Artikel auch angekündigt. Streisand-Effekt, was wir alle von Andy lernen können. Patriarchat, Tipps zur Überwindung fragider Männlichkeit, Puller-Alarm, Staatsanwaltschaft und Polizei drehen frei. Und die Hauptstory, Mensch, Andy, sei doch nicht so steif.
Also an unsere lieben Freundinnen und Freunde in Hamburg, wenn da noch was über ist, zwei Plakate und ein paar Aufkleber wären bei uns in guten Händen. In Hamburg werden die ja eh die ganze Zeit abgerissen von der Polizei. Vielleicht haben wir in Berlin noch eine Chance. Nee, aber da würde ich mich sehr über Zuschriften freuen. Tims Versandadresse steht ja im Impressum unter metaebene.me.
Die Macher haben allerdings auch einen Twitter-Account. Das nervt jeden. Die Gruppe nennt sich Dies Irae, was so viel heißt wie Tag des Zorns.
Aber genau, das war dann mein Instagram-Launch, dass ich nämlich, als ich in Hamburg war, selbstverständlich auf Instagram macht man ja Selfies. Ich mache nicht so viele Selfies deswegen, weil diese Plattform für mich jetzt nie so interessant ist. Aber ich habe ein Foto vor der roten Flora gemacht. Und tatsächlich, so viel kann ich auch noch verraten, wir waren halt zu dritt vor der Tür und haben uns dann geräuschvoll erfreut. Und es dauerte nicht lange, bis oben aus dem Fenster Leute kamen, die quasi erstaunlich schnell bereit waren zur Verteidigung ihres Werkes. Und dann aber gesehen haben, dass von uns jetzt erstmal keine Gefahr ausging. Und wir waren jetzt auch nicht die Einzigen, die sich da angesammelt haben, um halt vor diesem einmaligen Werk zeitgenössischer Kunst ein Selfie zu machen. Schön, da ist das Internet dann doch immer wieder schön.
Manchmal ganz lustig. Ja, einfach um so ein bisschen Entlastung, mentale Entlastung zu schaffen. Auch wenn das natürlich am Ende nicht viel macht. Diese Soko-Wand und Farbe, das war mir ja auch neu, die gibt es ja offensichtlich auch schon seit Ewigkeiten. Das ist jetzt nichts, was jetzt neu eingeführt wurde, sondern es gab irgendwie 2008 schon so einen schönen extra drei Berichter drüber.
Das ist der, auf den ich mich bezogen habe.
Genau, und das ist im Wesentlichen dazu da, linke Parolen zu übertünchen, wenn ich das so richtig sehe. Da fragt man sich halt auch, so Hakenkreuze und so, könnte der dann nicht auch noch übernehmen? Gut, vielleicht malen die ja nochmal manches über. Aber ich erinnere mich auch wiederum an eine ältere Dame, war es in Dresden oder so, wo die gelebt hat, du kennst die Story wahrscheinlich auch, deren Hauptwerk das ist, irgendwie die ganze Zeit, Hakenkreuze zu übermalen und Nazi-Aufkleber abzumachen, die dann auch immer mal dafür verklagt wurde. Also das ist einfach alles so falsch und so schräg und so kaputt. Insofern muss ich sagen, ist dann auch mal so eine gehörige Trachtprüge in Form von Hämme und Sport auch mal ganz angemessen, dass ihr einfach auch mal merkt, wo die Grenzen eures überheblichen Handelns zu sein haben.
Es geht ja vor allem, also hier sind zwei Dinge mal relevant. Also erstens, wenn wir uns gerade noch über den Drachenlord unterhalten, da gibt es natürlich einen Unterschied zwischen dem Drachenlord und dem Innen-Senator der Hansestadt Hamburg oder des Stadtstaates Hamburg, besteht spezifisch darin, dass niemand, niemand die Gelegenheit hat, als Reaktion auf einen Tweet mit dem Inhalt, du bist so eins Pimmel, eine Hausdurchsuchung zu veranlassen bei der Urheberin des Tweets. Damit geht es los. Das ist hier das Kräfteverhältnis, von dem man reden muss. Wenn ich in den Drachenkanal gehe und unter ein YouTube-Video von dem schreibe, du bist so eins Pimmel, und er würde das zur Anzeige bringen, dann würden alle sagen, was willst du denn für einen vollen Idiot belästige die Polizei, bitte nicht damit. Sicherlich nicht, würde er bei mir eine Hausdurchsuchung schreiben.
Und du hättest 10.000 Follower mehr.
Ja, so und jetzt, damit geht es los. Das wiederum, muss man ja sehen, ist eine brachiale Machtdemonstration der Polizei und ein Missbrauch der Macht des Innensenators, dass er eben sich hier einen sehr viel besseren rechtlichen Schutz für seine fragile Männlichkeit sucht und gestattet, als zum Beispiel meiner fragilen Männlichkeit zugestanden würde. Und das ist der eigentliche Skandal hier. Dass der Protest dagegen oder die Illustration dessen in Form dieser Aufkleber und der Plakate und der Flora-Aktion stattfindet, ist kein Fall von Mobbing, sondern letztendlich ein Aufbäumen des Restes von uns, der Gesellschaft, gegen einen ganz eklatanten Machtmissbrauch und auch eine Geldverschwendung. Ich meine, da rennen jetzt Polizisten rum und kratzen irgendwelche Aufkleber ab. Wo sind wir denn? Wenn ihm die Aufkleber nicht gefallen, soll er die selber abmachen oder sich bei Helps da jemanden holen. Aber dafür jetzt auch noch hier die mit teuren Steuergeldern in Hamburg finanzierte Polizei zu vergeuden, das ist ja wirklich ein Skandal und den möchte ich hier wirklich nicht aus den Augen verlieren.
Genau, haben wir hiermit dann nicht getan. Hier wird alles angeprangert, was anzuprangern ist. Jetzt haben wir uns aber ausgeprangert. Oder?
Ja, Tim, du bist so ein Spimmel.
Na ja, du auch.
Zeig dich an.
Anzeige ist raus.
Also da muss ich natürlich auch sagen, es gibt immer einen, der beleidigt und einen, der sich beleidigen lässt.
Können nix ab.
Sag mal, steht in den Showdots jetzt wegen Autokorrektur, Andy, du bist so eins Himmel oder weil du Angst hast, dass wir auch eine Hausversuchung kriegen?
Nee, das war in der Tat Autokorrektur. Tja, sogar die Autokorrektur ist auf der Seite der Polizei. Soko-Autokorrektur.
So, damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung. Genau, Twitter-Accounts folgen, Instagram keine Sorgen. Oh ja, jetzt kommen wir die Kommentare. Linus, dein Instagram-Account. Da freue ich mich schon oft.
Ich habe auch einen Instagram-Account, aber ich weiß nicht, wie viele Posts hast du da schon gemacht?
20 oder so.
Du bist schon richtig am Arbeiten, so Social Media-mäßig und so.
Ich möchte meine Reichweite in Richtung von Kindern und Jugendlichen ausbauen. Mit Facebook habe ich da einfach eine gute Partnerin.
Ich fühle mich jetzt herausgefordert, da auch irgendwie zu sein, weil ich mich ansonsten minderwertig fühle. Jetzt muss ich so sein wie du.
Guck mal, wie viel ich habe. Ich habe mehr Instagram-Posts. 36 Posts.
Mehr als was?
36 Posts auf Instagram habe ich gemacht.
Wahnsinn. Ich glaube, ich habe einen. Oder zwei. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau. Das erste war ein Test und das zweite auch. Ich wollte halt einfach wissen, ne stimmt gar nicht, ich habe vier. Ich habe vier. Vier. Na ja, kannst mal sehen, ich bin ganz schön ambitioniert. Du Social Media, kannst noch was lernen. Na ja, bin ja mehr so ein Twitter-Typ. Leute, wir entlassen euch.